welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel's the eternals is
starting to reveal some major
chunks of its mystery plot with its
director chloe zou
and star kumail nanjiani hinting at its
epic scale
and if you were reading between those
lines dropping a huge clue for how this
film will link the msu's past with its
future
potential spoilers ahead because we are
uncovering the eternals plot in mcu's
phase four plan
by diving deep into camille's abs with
another new rockstar sweet girl
so a quick reminder of what the eternals
are just to give you a quick refresher
the eternals are immortal beings living
in secret on earth since
ancient times the cast includes gemma
chan as cersei
richard madden as icarus angelina jolie
as thina kamehameha as kingu
salma hayek as ajack brian tyree henry
as fastos lauren ridloff as makari
liam mchugh as sprite don lee as
gilgamesh barry kogan as droog and kit
harrington
is playing dane whitman a human who
falls in love with cersei the eternals
were created as an experiment by the
celestials
thousands of years ago celestials are 20
giant armored space gods three have
appeared in mcu
east on the searcher and guardians of
the galaxy ego and guardians vol 2 and
the severed celestial head of nowhere
the celestials put the eternals on earth
to defend the planet from the evil
deviants and while they were doing this
they also created mankind and mutant
kind
helping us understand how the hell
director chloe zao will adapt this in
the film delayed to february 2021
has been cabell nagioni who recently
tweeted quote the movie will be
worth the wait it's the most exciting
fun epic thrilling hilarious and moving
project i've ever been a part of and
it's
massive the scale of it is unlike
anything i've ever seen
i would walk on a shoot and be awestruck
by the sets every day
so we get it bigger than endgame way to
set those expectations at a reasonable
height
mail but camille's statements hit us
after an article about director chloe
zao in which kevin feige sang her
praises
saying her initial pitch to us was
fascinating and frankly one of the
reasons we moved forward with the movie
was because the vision she brought to it
the article goes on to say that zhao
embedded in the film a theme rooted in
her childhood
she said i have such deep strong manga
roots i brought some of that into
eternals and i look forward to pushing
more of that marriage of east
and west she says the film is literally
about the history of humanity
quote how much further and bigger can we
go after
endgame because i'm not just making the
film as a director i'm making the film
as
a fan whoa we actually are seriously
aiming for
bigger than end game got it but before
we continue losing your hair is a bummer
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35
we don't want that we'll get cold well
with keeps it's easier and more
affordable to get treatment for your
hair loss and help you keep the hair
that you have
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out there but at half the cost of your
local pharmacy
and you don't even have to go to a
doctor's office you can do it all from
home
where you're probably stuck right now
you meet with a doctor online and they
ship the treatment
right to your home find out why keeps
has more five five-star reviews than
any of its competitors and nearly a
hundred thousand men trust keeps for the
hair loss prevention medication so if
you're noticing that you're losing your
hair
do something about it for a limited time
go to keeps.com new rockstars or click
the link in the description to receive
50 percent off your first order what a
deal when it comes to nanjiani in
addition to making headlines with his
new
physique he also revealed in a podcast
interview last march that his eternal
character kingo took on the modern day
identity
of a famous bollywood movie star and
that he would be taking part in
an amazing bollywood dance sequence in
my character for instance
we were all like all right keep a low
profile nobody should know and so i go
and become a bollywood
movie star right that's like my secret
identity so i
we were all supposed to be like quiet
and i've become like the biggest
bodybuilders
i took months of bollywood dance classes
to prepare for that
it's really a workout and you know
there's like 52 dancers and 51 of them
are professional dancers and then
there's and then and then doesn't mean
but there was a statement a few minutes
earlier in this podcast episode
that caught my ear some riffing between
ajiani and the host about
thanos and for some reason thanos is
there yeah
yeah he's there i mean he's he's an
immigrant he is
that is true and he's a person of color
of color he is purple i believe yes
yes just a joke but as i learned in some
culty improv classes i spent thousands
of dollars in a decade of my life doing
there is truth and comedy and this kinko
actor calling thanos an
immigrant is interesting considering
thanos comic creator jim starlin
revealed earlier this year that he
believed young thanos would appear
in this eternals film so did nanjiani
just reveal a huge component of the
eternal's plot
it isn't just camilla gianni's thanos
joke in jim starlin's statement that
leads us to believe the eternals film
could show us
a thanos origin story or even the young
thanos concept art marvel has drawn up
in the past
see in the marvel comics thanos is
biologically and
eternal the son of eternals sui-san and
alars which infinity war went out of its
way to remind us of
both parents were eternals of titan but
thanos was born with the
freak deviant gene which made him an
outcast
now infinity war gave us only a little
of thanos's backstory on that planet
titan was like most planets too many
mouths
not enough to go around and when we
faced extinction i offered a solution
yes thanos suggests that the so-called
intelligent life of
utopia titan were skeptical of his
warnings of overpopulation
and ignored him until it was too late
catastrophic ruin
but why was thanos ignored is marvel
suggesting that even advanced
civilizations shrug off environmental
alarmists as being too
extreme i don't know about that zandar
has 12
billion people and three sons yet
manages to make it all work like if the
marvel universe can figure out
teleportation networks
i think they can manage their carbon
emissions i think it is possible that
thanos went ignored and made out to be
an extremist whose advice everyone did
the opposite of
because he was purple because he carried
a deviant gene
because he was an immigrant consider
how coincidental it is that much of the
action in this marvel universe is
centered around
this little unevolved pale blue dot tara
c-53 we didn't make the top 50 c's
i believe this eternal film is gonna
give us some big answers as to why earth
is so geocentric to this marvel universe
because
the celestials chose it chose earth as a
meek
unassuming innocent petri dish in which
to conduct their ancient experiments
that led to the eternals
the deviants humankind and mutant kind
but during those early stages there was
a mistake
a forbidden love affair that led to a
deviant gene
sneaking its way into the genetically
perfect eternal gene pool
leading generations later to this
delivery room uh-oh
thanos a child born from eternal parents
and
brought to the eternal's colony of titan
an
immigrant who grows up as an outsider
just trying to help his homeworld
but scorned as a freak i think the
tragedy of thanos will be how this
eternal's film goes
further and bigger than endgame to use
the director's words the
fascinating pitch that kevin feige was
alluding to
a re-contextualization of the villain of
the infinity saga
as a misunderstood other that's right
thanos did nothing wrong
he was just different and that theme of
ostracizing the other seems to be at the
core of zao's vision for the eternals
the love between dane whitman
and cersei is forbidden they are
star-crossed lovers one eternal one
human
and i'm willing to bet the deviants of
the story will be revealed to be
like the art i spend all my time
appreciating not
that deviant and so the counter theme of
tolerance
i believe will carry over into how the
eternals sets up marvel's future because
the most critical lesson the eternals
can learn from the tragedy of thanos
is that the freaky outsiders have a
place in society too
and that includes the other category of
intelligent life created by the
celestials on earth thousands of years
ago
mutants and while the marvel world made
the mistake of ignoring one genius baldy
until he tried to kill half of them
they're not gonna make the mistake
with the next bald weirdo to discuss
these marvel theories directly with me
join new rockstar's official discord
server which we offer to patrons of new
rockstars at any tier
just go to patreon.comrockstars follow
me on instagram
eavos follow new rockstars and subscribe
to new rock stars for breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
[Music]
you